that's done yeah it is the year 2016
it's a new year and with the new year
comes new things really we're starting
this new year off by trying to figure
out how to make a 360 rig and maybe even
figure out what kind of video ideas we
can shoot with it right that's crazy why
that happened
360 video is important because it is the
content of tomorrow and by tomorrow I
mean kind of the future all about holy
crap there's so many people it's to be
really hard to find them so there's no
way we're going to get thousand extras
so you just have to go to a place where
there's already a ton of people I think
we're just gonna have to straight-up
really shoot it because there's no you
don't need an operator for that you just
need someone to hit record if you put it
down and hit record and just like walk
away from it people look at and go oh
it's bunch of GoPros you know and not
going a video five of them as you can
see it's literally just a 3d printed rig
so that you can put a GoPro in it
vertically like this you know like
vertical phone you get a lot of up and
down but not too much left and right but
that's okay if you have a lot of cameras
looking left and right let's go to the
boardwalk on a Saturday or something
yeah yeah go to Puri and just like take
the thing and they like with the advent
of virtual reality this year more
virtual reality headsets coming out over
the next several years people are going
to start wanting to view content that
they can be immersed and you know
content that you can actually look
around and see but the issue is that the
vast majority of people do not have one
right now the best experience is
literally taking your phone and looking
around that's okay for what we're doing
right now so now you can see that it has
five GoPros here all pointed outwards
Wow nerd